with the nhs nightingale hospital a few
days from opening
the uk has recorded its first day of
more than 500 deaths
563 died in the country's hospitals in
24 hours
more will have died elsewhere and the
peak of the uk's epidemic
is still two or three weeks off the need
for this vast new coronavirus field
hospital is clear
managers say its open halls are an
advantage when the workforces are
absolute
limiting factor we have gone back to
what florence nightingale taught us
which is
if we can see you then we absolutely can
make sure that you're safe and well
cared for
we have been asked to be ready to open
this week and we will be
when it's fully operational there could
be 4 000 beds here
and other uk field hospitals are to
follow but although the uk is showing
that it can ramp up hospital capacity
like with the mega project nhs
nightingale london
the government is facing increasing
criticism for other aspects of its
coronavirus response
like the comparatively limited amount of
testing that's still being done
fewer than 10 000 a day this week
several times that amount are being done
in germany
national health service staff queue at
drive through testing centers
but many are being turned away they said
without a confirmation email there um
they won't get tested
so they're turning away nhs stuff now as
well so i don't understand like
why what the problem is just test the p
test you need to test the frontline
stuff so the test like
so the frontline stuff aren't passing on
the infection to other patients
on tuesday news broke of the uk's
youngest known victim yet
a 13 year old boy called ismail muhammad
abdul wahab
who had no apparent underlying health
conditions
because of the need and the way that
this virus
itself is no one else is allowed to be
around that individual and that means
you're on your deathbed
in your last moments alone and he was a
young boy
age 13 without his mother without any
sibling on his
on his death but in the last moments and
that's very hard to sort of digest
but largely covert 19 hits hardest older
people
and the already sick prince charles has
released a video statement after
recovering from his own encounter with
the disease
as a nation we are faced by a
profoundly challenging situation
which we are any to aware threatens the
livelihoods
businesses and welfare of millions of
our fellow citizens
none of us can say when this will end
but end it well and he praised the
medical staff who he described as
battling heroically
to save lives in hospitals across the
country rory challenge
al jazeera london